uh but ax is great as well I mean
actually but that was like definitely
for me that was what I was kind of like
the whole time yeah I mean you uh you
put so much work into this yeah months
super proud yeah super proud of you yeah
thank you thank you it's a great time
yeah and then ax was I mean I don't
really have too much to say about X ax
is just your normal kind of like ax
experience except this time we tried
building a booth and seeing what yeah
yeah we had we had a massive booth and
it was it was like it was fated right
because I looked at where our booth was
and I looked around and in one corner I
see fate go and in the other corner
right opposite I see Hoya verse I was
like
I'm standing with the Giants
I was like this is uh my entire career
has built up to this moment I have built
a booth starting next to fate go and my
entire career is in one room
so yeah we were next to the uh annaplex
fake go and booth and honestly like the
booth experience was pretty [__] good
you know I think everyone enjoyed it uh
everyone enjoyed okay first off uh first
thing I've I think we've realized claw
machines uh [__] [__] Hells holy
holy [__] okay so yeah we sort of
preface we're absolutely losing money on
the spirit yeah this booth is crazy yeah
so please buy the merch please imagine
how imagine how I feel I wasn't even
there and I'm losing money
so yeah we had a bunch of cool
attractions and I guess because when you
do these kind of booths in this scale
and this company's coming and helping
there's always going to be so much
miscommunication uh and you try not to
have that obviously and you try and work
towards it but there's a whole lot of
hiccups and stuff yeah and we rented
these claw machines because I thought we
we should really have claw machines yeah
because it's on Brands yeah it's on
brand and it's fun it's interactive
people can you know go and do it and
everyone knows claw machines are a great
scam so we would make money however we
did not make any [__] money so first
of all someone someone got scammed and
it was us
so okay first of all to rent I think
it's fine to say this yeah because they
totally scammed us uh everything's
cameras but so right renting four claw
machines is as expensive nearly as just
buying four kilometers yes yeah it was
twenty thousand dollars to rent four
claw machines for four days that is
insane that means five thousand dollars
to rent a claw machine for four days
when you could just buy the same thing
for like six that's more than a thousand
dollars a day yeah yeah a great method
but there it is yeah yeah it's [__] 12
50 a day yeah so like and there's no
show we will lose like making money on
these claw machines but we thought it
would be fun yeah um and then we were
like all right well let's let's make it
so that you can you can win some
exclusive stuff in it uh and I guess
there was just something that happened
in like I guess uh the the price to play
the claw machine did not equate to the
prizes you would get and by what I mean
by that is that you could pay five bucks
and get three tokens which I think is
supposed to be one or something it
wasn't supposed to be that so you get
three turns and this claw was definitely
okay you would win every single time if
you lined it up it was impossible to
lose it just paid a win yeah whereas
normal claws would pick it up and drop
this was like the [__] grip of Zeus
it would not let go and so you would
people there was dudes lining up buying
like a [__] ton of tokens and just
farming yeah winning everything and then
I think they were just either giving it
away or selling it all right because the
stuff you would get was worth more than
what you paid yeah so and even if we
sold it at that price we would lose
money just free money glitches yeah yeah
yeah that was kind of a like a bit of a
mess but I think it was fun on top of
like how much we pay to rent them I
think two of them just broke yeah two of
them just didn't work yeah and it's like
what the [__] is the point
so uh lesson learned don't rent claw
machines yeah and buy them before
someone says oh why did you put like a
claw machines or Gadget machines so in
order to get like it it's all to do with
like the rules of an expo like Anime
Expo itself so if you want uh and like a
boost there right depending on where you
are you need to meet certain requisites
about how much space that Booth takes
and what's going to be in that Booth so
to be in the entertainment Hall a
certain percentage of the your booth has
to be interactive yeah so there's two
holes or the main uh LA Convention
Center yeah one of them is kind of like
a bigger entertainment Hall and there's
a lot more room and it's a bit nicer and
the exhibition Hall where it's just
people selling stuff which is yeah which
is kind of like the main hall sorry I'm
burping sorry that's that's why we not
only had the claw machines there but we
also had the replica setup like this
setup yeah the cardboard cutouts which
were like popping off from what I saw on
um and uh yeah yeah so we had to we had
to put some stuff in it and then we had
the giant gotcha machine which we
thought would be fun yeah but the
catching machine was like it was kind of
like messed up it just didn't work
properly
um but we did give away some of the set
so the Aquila bike's gone yeah like
Goku's gone like Goku is gone as well
and I think the Fate statue that was on
the after dark is gone would give those
away to people that ax yep and so shout
out to those people I'm sure they were
very happy yeah you got the SSR pools
man what can I say you got a piece of
trash taste law yeah yeah yeah but I
like London it was ungodly expensive to
run a booth at ax his ungodly expenses
please buy the merch again please go to
trashtaste.com in the description I mean
buy some merch because it looks fire
okay like you know speaking for you
we'll be honest yeah yeah speaking for
real you know we kind of did this as
kind of like an experiment just to see
what it is what it is like to run a
booth at ax specifically X I don't know
about other conventions and uh like any
advice to anyone or any company that is
thinking about purchasing Booth space in
a Convention as large as ax is that the
real value you get is the value of like
marketing yourself and having a presence
where at a space where everyone else is
present you know it's was mostly surreal
seeing myself uh and my I guess like
ourselves next to [__] someone else
like employer verse and Studio Ghibli
wait it's a dick measuring contest yeah
all this stuff is if all the companies
go there that's all the booth is yeah
yeah because like the the reality of
like uh of like how a lot of these
businesses function is that although
they have obviously they make most of
their money from uh us the consumers and
whatnot you know a lot of these like big
business deals are just at the whim of
like like a few businessmen who like can
be so you can you don't usually like
realize how how impactful it can be to
just see a gigantic like fate thing and
then the businessman must be thinking
like Fate's huge yeah it's Fate's
crushing it we should work with fate
yeah because they and maybe you wouldn't
associate with the booth but like just
having that kind of presence and working
with these these brands or whatever like
yeah they have a booth there they must
be legit it's such a weird business uh
it is and I think I think for us we were
just like we just wanted to do it I
think it'd be fun we're legit guys
please please
everything we were just like [__] it
yeah like you said we just want to be
like [__] it what would what would
having a booth at ax be like yeah
biggest Anime Con I guess we're the
biggest anime podcast
which is very undeserved
and so we just thought [__] it what
would it be like and it was it was crazy
it was a little fun yeah I mean I mean
it's this inside thing has just taught
me because you know
we even though we sit in our rooms and
we make [__] anime videos and all
that [__] uh it's kind of like just this
entire Journey itself has just taught me
a lot about just marketing and what that
means on just like the grander scale of
things yeah because if you say that you
want to start a business and you don't
know anything about marketing you will
100 learn about Marketing in some way
shape or form and I say this as an
engineer that has not taken a single
marketing course I haven't signed up to
[__] any dodgy online course about
how to Market yourself because you learn
so much on the job of just how important
marketing or none of us have ever really
like studied marketing at school or
anything yeah I mean we're in a
fortunate fortunate position where we
can be like [__] it let's lose money on
a booth like yeah yeah like let's just
do it because we want to see how it goes
and I think that it'd be a fun learning
experience for us and that we can see if
this is saying we want to pursue yeah
yeah and do again I mean I mean for me
I'm always on just a journey of like
trying to learn as much as I can you you
know you learn that there are some
things you experience that you cannot
immediately quantify but just I think
having that experience of just running a
booth and just what it's like behind the
scenes we've gained like experience and
know-how that well there's only so much
you can learn from like a book right
yeah or like watching YouTube videos
yeah you have to like actually put
yourself into it to be like oh so this
is how it actually is yeah and that's
what the trash days booth for us was
um especially me I am such an awful
learner when it comes to just like
reading [__] I'm that [__] who
plays a video game and I go through the
tutorial and I read what what like the
tutorial is trying to tell me I'm like
this means nothing I'm like I'm like
what the [__] are the game mechanics and
then I actually like play the game
mechanics I'm like oh I get it it like
clicks in and it internalizes itself for
me I feel like you're not the minority I
don't know I feel like I feel there's a
lot of people I think most people like
to try yeah trial and error yeah a lot
of people just you know there's this
whole like I'm a practical in it it's
all [__] everyone's a [__]
practical learner yeah everyone's going
to learn better if you let them do it
yeah of course you will what do you
[__] do you you're so stupid yeah so
yeah obviously I think a lot of people
some people can can absorb information
better but I think everyone learns the
best when you have hands-on experience
yeah I think that's that's you know I
think everyone can agree to that well
that's why like every job application
you go to they ask for how much
experience you've had not how many books
you've already yeah also I feel like a
lot of people because I I I am in some
ways in this camp where a lot of people
have this idea of like something they
want to do and then they spend 10 000
hours of research on how to do it
correctly just don't do it and then they
just don't do it yeah because you know
you know we try to do as much research
as we can doing like new stuff or new
things on how to do it correctly
something is going to go wrong our tour
was not perfect there are there are you
know for example our tour we we had an
idea that we want to do a tour a live
show it did not go perfectly some things
went wrong with the logistics of some
shows and everything but it's all like
learning I was expected as well yeah
yeah yeah and you got to give yourself
credit if you have any ideas that you
want to do so [__] up a bit to fail a
bit you know you gotta you gotta give
yourself a little bit of leeway
um and I feel like more people should
think you know if someone's doing
something new I think I feel like there
should be a bit of leeway given as well
you know obviously not everything's
gonna go perfect they're going to try
the best they can but as long as they
tried the best they can and it's not a
[__] massive [__] up to like a
gargantuan scale then you know it's yeah
it's not about taking risks it's about
taking intelligent risks yeah right it's
about like okay you can use all of this
like knowledge you've gained from like
reading books you know not actually
physically doing something and then from
there you can be like all right I'm
gonna try and do this thing now yeah
with the knowledge that I have it might
not be the most perfect knowledge that I
have it might not be the most like
logistical knowledge that I have but I
know I have enough knowledge in me that
I know that taking this particular risk
will probably work out better for me
than taking this ridiculous route yeah
yeah and that's all about that yeah and
I also don't want it to sound like oh
you gotta buy a merch like cover up our
[__]
Connor's saying that I'm saying this is
generally some like one of our my
favorite merch shops that we've done I
actually love this much uh of course
there's a denim jacket so of course it
was gonna be one of my favorites but I
generally I generally like love what we
did and uh yeah I'm looking forward to
wearing it in the future okay you know
uh